it's it's actually a very good point
that yeah
yeah it's actually because i did say
like yeah what if in the future like our
sports is run by
trans like there's more trans women than
biological women
and i'm just like then there wouldn't be
any women supporting
men and trans women sports
is that that is such a good point
that's like a stupid good point yeah
cause like
because that's what i always think of
like from a policy perspective you have
to think of the extreme like even with
the bathrooms right yeah what's the
extreme of that
shed
oh no what's the extreme of like letting
trans men into the women's bathroom
[Music]
yeah
that's because you always like when i
think of a policy perspective like like
there's so many people you have to think
of the extreme
and this like now because they didn't
stop it eight years ago when caitlyn
jenner like took that title that she
shouldn't have had
now now we see the extreme
and it's like almost like vote culture
or whatever like they didn't stop it
early i wonder who else was in the
running for that um
that award what we can google it and
what else caitlyn
they did to be considered courage award
nominees courageous woman um
and if it's maybe i do agree with the
like maybe just a league or like they
could have a cree uh
like a courageous trans woman award
yeah like like we're not we're not like
excluding yeah it's just it's just that
like
there there is if there was no
difference then
there wouldn't be men and women we would
just all
play together actually why don't we just
look at who got the sb award in 2022
oh
it's called the sb i've never really
even heard of it and i didn't care back
then but i just think of now as like we
see the repercussions
um women's tennis
um kyle murray
paige oh yukon basketball you know what
that is oh is that um i don't know i
don't think i know that i don't know how
it works i'm gonna be honest but you
guys get what i'm saying like it's
almost like if we don't stop it early
like the the extremes happen yeah okay
wait let me keep reading um
two dollar super chat from the water the
trans dude blew the woman right off of
me
oh the water
you get it
the water the water super chatted two
dollars and said the trans woman blew
the women right on
doug mpa 2010. no men i know or no men i
know are down with trans women competing
against biological women the majority of
us men don't want this why are women
giving away their sport
why why
why do women do that like we
you guys are doing it now i know
i'm trying to figure it out
like
yeah
but it's like we were saying earlier
it's like that empathy and we don't and
we don't want to be the person to speak
up yeah because it's not it's not like i
i don't think it's natural to women to
like go into conflict like i just think
men are better at it
yeah it's like we're saying like
we
this dang
person made a good point
and like essentially like if it keeps
going if we keep making this exception
there's going to be
more and more trans women athletes that
are going to come out and play the
sports and it's going to be more and
more to where there's less and less
biological women that have those
opportunities to play and scholarships
are going to be taken
spots on proteins are going to be taken
because
i mean
naturally to the natural eye if you look
on a piece of paper and you don't know
if a person is a trans woman or a
biological man you see this skill sales
skill set blah blah blah and then you
see oh they're six six and you have a
511 person and the skill set is the same
i'm gonna pick the six six person and
then you find out as a trans woman
you're just like
okay well they're six six so it's okay
it's like
there's going
there
there will come a point where it's just
we won't have a shot
anymore
and
there's nothing
physically nothing we can do about it to
train ourselves to be able to
compete with men yeah
yeah and it's like and that's so sad
like that makes my like i love
people people think i don't because i
say men are better than women but i love
women's sports like i don't think i
would be who and where i am today if i
didn't have sports exactly like i would
even go as far as to say like it it like
saved me out of like rough situation and
i think a lot of athletes would like say
that
and like the thought of just having like
these guys like
like dressed as women kicking our asses
yeah it would
it would suck but like
like
i think they they like people should
really consider like
making another
another
another
or just like
yeah another league and it just be
the trans league and
that's the fairest
way to do it yeah
yeah like
you can try you can try like trans from
a man to a woman but mm-hmm like as
we've stated
biologically you're still
a man underneath like you can't identify
as a woman we'll all identify like we'll
all say you are yeah
like you're still going to be better
than us physically like physically so
it's only fair for them to have their
own league if they want to be identified
as a woman yeah yeah
and essentially
i don't know how
like
money works with schools and where they
get it from but i i would think that
you'd be able to get more money if you
have
trans athletes because you would want to
schools may want to promote that more
it's schools love promoting the best
things out there and so you'd be able to
get more grants from people who
maybe are trans uh men or women that
they don't know you're donating and
i think it it'd be something to consider
no i would agree actually i would be
fine with a third league or even a
league where like men and women can
compete against each other if they want
to
but it's also back to like we i think
you said this on one episode where
a lot of like you don't know that
they're trans going in
and so there was a fighter that did this
and this fighter was just kicking
women's ass and then it came out that
they were trans i don't know i i can't
say the name i don't even know real
people's names
i'm not gonna know
yeah and i'd be cool with the trans
olympics but
i just oh my gosh
okay next next 50 sentience you are my
dude
you are my dude
what do you do what do you do for a
living because you kill it